hey everyone what's going on here's
gonna be my matrix resurrections review
now i'm gonna keep this as spoiler free
as possible if i do get into spoiler
territory because i'm trying to explain
the story i will let you know beforehand
or you that way you can mute or you can
fast forward but i'm gonna try to keep
this as spoiler-free as i can okay let's
talk about this film um of course this
is the fourth film in the matrix
franchise i liked the original first
like mini did out there two was okay
three wasn't so bad i was in the camp
where i was okay with three i
like the matrix more when it's in the
matrix versus when it's in the machine
is the machine's world and i think that
lana wachowski also recognized that the
audience liked that as well because you
do see that in resurrections that we are
more in the matrix world than we are in
the machines world uh so to speak i may
be saying that terminology wrong but you
you know what i'm talking about
anyway um for the most part in a
nutshell matrix resurrection is a love
story it is a sci-fi love story between
a couple that uh we you know for 20
years i mean neo and trinity
these two just light up the screen
they did back in the original matrix to
one two and three and they do now
and it's about their journey will they
get together will they you know what are
the trials and tribulations they face
what's holding them back that is really
what this movie is about so if you're on
board for somewhat of a love story it's
so sci-fi and it's still got a lot of
the elements of the matrix franchise in
there don't get me wrong it's a lot in
there and it's in a way it's sort of a
reboot which you kind of already know
that by now from the trailers and the
interviews out there but it really is a
love story and i gotta tell you keanu
reeves and carrie anne moss i love them
both together the chemistry between
these two is phenomenal they light up
the screen and without that chemistry
this movie fails tremendously now
um as i mentioned that's sort of the
gist of the story now if i was to sort
of uh condense this and say what's this
movie about what's it like i'll say it
this way inception meets free guy meets
mission impossible meets matrix that is
matrix resurrections in a nutshell okay
so we'll get a little more down to it by
talking about the actors and their
performances and then you can kind of
get a gist of what's happening here
first we got to talk about jessica
henwick who it plays bugs and she is i
mean this is a great vehicle for jessica
henwick i mean she was great in game of
thrones she had a smaller part back then
she was in star wars i think force
awakens if i'm not mistaken and then of
course she was an iron fist and she was
one of the better parts of iron fist she
really was i really enjoyed her she's
charismatic she's talented she's
beautiful
she pops on screen and this movie is
going to really catapult her this is a
fantastic vehicle for her as an actress
and she just knocks it out of the park
and i really liked her i mean she really
plays the captain of her crew that
really wants is that entering the matrix
and is trying to find neo and other
things that go on inside of it and she
really holds her own she does and i mean
i'm a fan let's talk about priyanka
chopra jonas yes because she's you know
fair to one of the jonas brothers
priyanka chopra jonas is um
she's in the film for a brief time she's
not in a lot
but she gets into this mission
impossible segment of the film and it
really is like mission impossible um
they're out to do this mission and it's
in the way they even talk about it and
the way they show the clips of how
they're doing it while they're talking
about it i mean i was waiting for tom
cruise to pop up on the screen really it
was
so blatant mission impossible that i was
like i even turned to a a friend of mine
that was watching with like
is ethan hunt gonna show up at any time
and he started laughing because it
really felt like that anyway
um she has a very integral part in the
film but she's not in it a lot she did a
great job with what she had uh very
believable in the role it was great but
again
we maybe get here for like five ten
minutes max i think thereabouts and
that's pretty much it then of course we
have morpheus who's played by yaya
abdulmatin and we've seen him in aquaman
and he is back playing morpheus and
he's he's a great actor there's nothing
wrong with his performance in this film
he is solid he's confident he has
elements of morpheus that we know from
lawrence fishburne
but
he's not lawrence fishburn
and
i know that i from what i understand
correct me if i'm wrong in the comment
section below is that lawrence fishburne
and hugo weaving wanted to be in this
film but either due to covet or due to
scheduling they weren't able to do it
and that is a very
unfortunate thing and it kind of holds
the film back from even being better
than it already is because you have such
an iconic
character in morpheus and you have such
an
a revered actor a renowned actor as
lawrence fishburne i mean he's one of
those guys it's like you're replacing
lawrence fishburne with someone else
who's also good but it's not the same
because lawrence fishburne is just so
solid in the role
and as a result this new morpheus is a
little flamboyant at times he's a little
bit out there he doesn't quite know
what's going on he's not really the
leader of this that's bugs so he's sort
of like
with bugs in a way at times it takes a
leadership role but at times he doesn't
it's a little bit weird how they have it
all positioned and i think that sort of
makes it a bit confusing for the
audience as well uh but it's
he did a great job
for the most part but
and they do reference lawrence fishman
mind you they do reference the original
morpheus
but you miss him you really do miss
fishburn in this role it does take you a
little bit out of it that this also goes
with agent smith played by jonathan
groff now
here's the thing about this film where
it could have been even better
is with any great film right with the
original matrix all the way to
the third matrix film you always had a
very strong antagonist that was hugo
weaving as agent smith he was so solid
his performance was
epic i mean
hello mr anderson how many people do
this to this day after so many years it
was iconic
and
jonathan groff plays agent smith and in
this matrix okay this may be a spoiler
so if you want to skip you can skip it i
just have to explain this portion of it
so you understand this video is brought
to you by secret lab here at geek
culture we love our secret lab chairs
especially the all new 2022 titan evo
with its revamped 4-way lumbar system
for enhanced back support if you leather
2.0 isn't your cup of tea then consider
the all-new soft weave even more soft
and breathable than before the chair
comes in more colors including this
lovely frost blue the titan evo is even
magnetized allowing the head pillow to
stick on the headrest without straps of
course there are even more new features
so do check them out at secretlab.com
in this world
you neo or agent smith or whatever the
case may be
they
will look different in this matrix but
we see them as the audience as the
character per se except agent smith
because he's not played by hugo weaving
but they do reference hugo weaving so
it's a little bit confusing at times but
without
hugo weaving who's so strong in this
role
this agent smith character
it loses a little bit of that impact and
you lose that strong antagonist now they
did try to uh supplement this with
another antagonist in the film which i'm
not going to give away because that will
be a big spoiler
but
it's not as strong as agent smith and
this character
really just um
i don't know i felt he was miscast i'll
just put it that way anyway let's move
on to neil patrick harris who plays the
analyst or the psychiatrist that we've
seen in many of the trailers and his
role is very interesting i mean this is
a very deep role and it's um
in a sense i think we've got from the
trailers that he's trying to keep uh
thomas anderson in the matrix we do see
him taking the blue pills we do see him
prescribing these blue pills so you kind
of get a sense that he's really
controlling thomas anderson and they've
taken a different approach with anderson
versus how that was in the original
matrix movies um i think they try to
learn their lesson so to speak but uh
he's great as the psychiatrist neil
patrick harris is great in that but
his character does evolve a little bit
and when it does evolve
it um it takes an interesting turn and i
don't know
he's great actor phenomenal performance
but i don't know if it actually
rises to the level of what we need it to
be in the film i'll just leave it at
that because i don't want to spoil too
much for you but
um
very cool to see neil patrick harrison
anyway i've always been a fan from the
doogie hauser days that's how i knew him
anyway let's talk about the two big
stars keanu reeves and carrie anne moss
let's go with carrie anne moss first
okay
i
i like many guys probably uh when we
first first saw the uh the matrix and
two and three we fell in love with
carrie anne moss's trinity and i
absolutely loved her back then and i
love her now i even liked her jessica
jones um
i'm a big fan of carrie moss i think
she's a fantastic talent uh beautiful
woman but just very very talented
and she just comes guns of blazing in
this role she's so so good in it she's
so so good in it it really is
um she doesn't miss a beat you know yes
you do see the age coming up on both
keanu and karen moss i mean can that she
do all the crazy stunts that she once
did not as quite as fluid as trinity in
the years past but
she holds her own really really well
she just lights up on screen you know
just i had a crush on her back on the
matrix and i had my crushes
resurged and i'm a big fan anyway
um she comes in this uh rule
i don't i can't talk much about her
character in this because that gives
away a lot of the film so i'm not gonna
do that but i will say that uh she rises
to the occasion in more ways than one
keanu reeves let's talk about keanu
reeves thomas anderson for a lot of the
film
and uh as you can see you did see some
of the trailer he does get into his
neo-esque form but uh
yeah
when we watch the matrix and neo we want
to see
neo really
kick a lot of ass and you see some of it
in the trailers and you see some of it
you know and when he does his interviews
and they show some clips and he does a
really good job i mean hell is john wick
right keanu reeves can he can still
fight and he does a pretty damn good job
in this but
you may walk out of this
wanting more from the character neo
i'll just leave it at that i will just
leave it at that
um i can't see anything more to spoil
for you but i wanted to see neo as neo
but it isn't neo as we know neo a
hundred percent it's kind of like
70 80 percent of neo so that's all i can
say right now maybe i'll do a review
where it's i can spoil the whole film
and we can talk more about it but uh
nonetheless as i mentioned earlier in
this video i mean counter reeves and
carry on moss together are
phenomenal
i mean the way they look at each other's
eyes it's kind of you know reminded me
of
and we put in just more you know current
movie uh context is like bradley cooper
and lady gaga you know like when they on
the academy awards when they were
singing together in that chemistry and
everybody thought okay these two are
really dating that's how these two look
on screen they just
there is a
a fire in between these two that just is
undeniable and lana wachowski captured
that beautifully uh and it really made
the film better without it if it didn't
have that the film would not really be
that good at all so my final thoughts on
matrix resurrections
i enjoyed it
i wasn't wowed by the film i thought it
was a very nice love story
i did as i mentioned earlier phil that
there was not a proper antagonist to
really match
neo and the journey with trinity and all
that kind of stuff to really match that
storyline and as a result it felt flat
in that regard some of the exposition
parts were a little bit draggy and at
times i was fidgeting in the seat going
okay i've been there done that let's
move on but i think it's a fun film and
if you're a matrix fan it's definitely a
must watch i mean if you're a little bit
worried about going into the cinema
right now if you're in america you can
watch it on hbo max on the same date and
i would say
it's definitely you can definitely enjoy
it on hbo max
of course it's great to see it in imax
or see it on a big screen because of the
sound and the visuals i mean it's just a
beautiful beautifully made film
but
if you're worried you're not gonna miss
too much by watching on hbo max anyway
those are my thoughts on it anyway let
me know your thoughts in the comment
section below like always follow us on
facebook subscribe to us on youtube be
safe out there and have a merry
christmas and i'll chat to you soon take
care